bonsoir vous aussi des titres de
l'actualité de ce 18 octobre procès à
guingamp de l'abbé jean yves quotas a
jugé pour homicides et blessures
involontaires après la noyade en 98 de
quatre scouts et d'un plaisancier venus
les secourir
procès à evry de l'époux d'une mère de
paris xavière tiberi et du sénateur rpr
xavier dugoin où il est question des
emplois présumés fictifs du conseil
général de leicester dit le constructeur
automobile japonais nissan ce contrôle
de renault va supprimer 21 mille emplois
et fermer cinq usines c'est le choix
drastiques faite par le dirigeant
français de nissan
l'équipe italienne ferrari at elle
triché en modifiant un élément de
carrosserie pour aller plus vite
polémique en italie sur ce qui pourrait
coûter 2 titres de champion du monde à
la scuderia
cinéma l'été de kikujiro le dernier film
du japonais takeshi kitano la balade
d'un gamin sur les routes du japon
alors bien sûr ça ne prouve rien mais il
y avait comme un sourire mais pas le
moindre remords apparents sur le visage
de l'abbé jean yves costard lorsqu'il
s'est présenté en soutane devant le
tribunal correctionnel de guingamp dans
les côtes d'armor le prg est intégriste
doit répondre d'homicide et blessures
involontaires accusés d'avoir provoqué
la mort de cinq personnes dont quatre
enfants scouts par manquement délibéré
aux obligations de sécurité de prudence
imposée par la loi fin de citation bien
sûr autour de l'abbé cottard on dénonce
un lynchage médiatique mais il y a la
mort de quatre scouts et d'un
plaisancier venus les secourir c'était
le 22 juillet 1998 compte rendu
d'audience tirer curtet à 18 h
c'est en soutane un missel sous le bras
que l'abbé cottard décide de paraître
devant ses juges
autour de lui de nombreux prêtres de la
congrégation traditionaliste saint pie
10 venus le soutenir et les parents des
victimes se sont ainsi ce matin aux
côtés des témoins de moralité de
l'ecclésiastique avant d'évoquer
l'accident les cinq morts la présidente
a voulu comprendre l'organisation du
camp de scouts catholiques et elle
constate que tous les verrous de
sécurité avaient sauté
ou qu'un moniteur diplômé aucun test de
natation surnombre dans les voiliers
improvisation durée de côté quand les
difficultés arrivent personne ne sait
faire face
l'inventaire malheureusement n'est pas
terminée car un nombre certain d'autres
carences sont apparus lors du naufrage
lui même lors du raid nous allons je
pense tout à l'heure malheureusement ce
n'est pas terminé il ya d'autres choses
qui seront mis en évidence l'abbé
cottard et ses défenseurs se retrouvent
dans les cordes assommés par
l'enchaînement des événements tels que
les a constaté le tribunal
lorsqu'on met tout ça à plat comme c il
ya quelque chose d'artificiel qu'il faut
savoir que un camp scout ya une équipe
qui marche en osmose permanente on c'est
un problème de 2,2
de confiance réciproque les uns les
autres je sais c'est une troupe qui a
déjà quinze vingt ans d'existence
le savoir se transmet de génération en
génération de chefs en chef plusieurs
fois la présidente tentera d'y voir plus
clair et posera cette même série de
questions aux témoins qui organisait je
ne sais pas quelles étaient les diplômes
dans ce camp je ne sais pas qui décident
est toujours la même réponse de la part
des projets l'abbé cottard je ne sais
pas devant le tribunal correctionnel
d'evry on attendait cet après-midi
xavière tiberi épouse du maire de paris
en compagnie du sénateur rpr xavier
dugoin et de deux autres prévenus elle
doit répondre d'une affaire d'emplois
présumés fictifs au conseil général de
l'essonne alors présidé par xavier
dugoin la première journée furent
surtout occupé par les avocats de la
défense qui sollicitèrent en vain le
renvoi du procès en arguant de nullité
de procédure comme le rapporte dominique
verdeilhan une haie d'honneur pour ravir
tiberi qui pénètre dans la salle
d'audience en fait il s'agit de protéger
les pousses du maire de paris du regard
indiscret des photographes et des
cameramen dans le prétoire même
protection avocat et garde du corps site
écrans entré par une porte dérobée
xavière tiberi n'a donc pas croisé les
membres du comité de soutien pour la
plupart ce sont des employés de la
mairie de paris
on l'a vu déjeuner avec nous bon bah
mettez-vous à sa place celle des rimes
provient il faut quand même penser que
c'est une femme en toute chose on n'a
pas entrer dans le point de la justice
mais elle est conne stress et tous les
jours moi je voi est la presse depuis
quelques jours sans arrêt ce monsieur-là
mme tiberi en première ligne dans tous
les journaux on comprend qu'il ya peut
être un petit peu fatigué et c'est pour
ça qu'on est venu alors que dans la
salle des pas perdus on joue des coudes
pour être aux premières loges dans le
prétoire les avocats de xavière tiberi
et xavier dugoin eux font tout pour en
sortir demande de renvoi sursis à
statuer nullité de procédure le tribunal
a tout entendu car pour la défense la
première procédure ayant été annulée en
97 il est impossible d'intenter un
second procès
madame tiberi a fait l'objet d'un
acharnement vraiment odieux et injuste
il s'agit aujourd'hui de démonter le
mécanisme de cet acharnement est de
montrer que cet acharnement à poser des
vis procéduraux gravissime qui ne
s'était pas produit depuis des siècles
dont le conseil général de l'essonne
seule la perquisition chez les tiberi a
été annulé cette exposition est annulé
mais elle n'a pas annulé le rapport
parce que ce n'est pas une pièce
judiciaire on n'annule pas pièce qui
n'est pas judiciaire et puis deux
surfeurs et c'est ça le problème si elle
n'est pas annulée madame tiberi
durant les cinq heures d'audience les
oreilles du procureur de la république
laurent davenas absent à l'audience ont
dû siffler au centre les plaidoiries des
avocats de la défense il a focalisé
l'attention reléguant au second plan ce
qui l'avait poursuivi
nissan le constructeur automobile
japonais est en mauvaise santé c'est le
diagnostic fait par le nouveau patron
français carlos ghosn venu de renault et
après le diagnostic et diane remède il
est violent 21 mille emplois supprimés
cinq usines fermées ce qui autorisait
aujourd'hui à tokyo certains
observateurs a parlé d'une méthode à la
vilvorde référence à la manière dont
renault décidé à l'affirmer de lusine
vilvoorde en belgique reportage de nos
envoyés spéciaux au japon l'une des 6 1
et roger mathurin dans les rues de tokyo
les voitures sont nombreuses mais les
renault se font extrêmement rare et pour
cause la marque française ne représente
que 0 point 0 10% du marché automobile
japonais et pourtant aujourd'hui tous
les regards se sont tournés vers cet
homme carlos ghosn ancien numéro deux de
renault et nouveau vice président de
nissan depuis que le constructeur
français a racheté plus de 36% du
capital du japonais chacun c'est ici que
les observations de carlos ghosn sur les
sites industriels devaient aboutir à des
décisions douloureuses
finalement le nouvel homme fort de
nissan annonce entre autres la fermeture
de cinq usines au japon
10 mines ceci va se traduire par une
réduction de 21 mille postes soit une
baisse de 14% du nombre de salariés
un choc pour les japonais habitués à
l'idée de garder leur emploi pour la vie
même si la direction de nissan les
rassure en leur parlant de pré-retraite
et de départs volontaires construit en
image de manager redoutable c'était un
peu estompée mais s'il applique son plan
de manière draconienne sa réputation va
de nouveau se dégrader hasard du passé
ou prémonition deux concessionnaires 1
renault l'autre nissan co existent déjà
dans cette même rue de tokyo mais
l'alliance n'est pas encore effective
dans l'esprit des japonais que les
voitures soit étrangère japonaise se
pressaient pour chacune des marques
carrière ce mardi avec nos spécificités
nationales et que l'on ne pense pas
d'amiante
je prenais une personne qui travaille
chez nissan et elle s'inquiète car elle
ne voit pas très bien ce que va devenir
son emploi nissan société orgueilleuse
qui prédisaient la disparition de
plusieurs constructeurs européens perd
de l'argent depuis sept ans et écoutent
aujourd'hui les conseils de son
partenaire français cette concession
nissan par exemple le risque de faire
prochainement les frais de cette
nouvelle logique de restructurations en
entrant dans le capital de nissan
renault s'est engagé à prendre des
mesures difficiles le tout sera de les
faire accepter par les japonais
la société française thomson multimédia
quatrième groupe mondial d'électronique
grand public va procéder à une
augmentation de capital et une entrée en
bourse au mois de novembre prochain
l'état va donc réduire sa présence dans
cette société thomson multimédia à
présent investi plus de 10 milliards de
francs de relance et après surtout qu'on
est entendu en novembre 96 le premier
ministre de l'époque alain juppé affirmé
qu'elle ne valait rien depuis le rien
est devenue beaucoup voyez les
explications de florence des efforts
avec valérie luc
son entreprise la failli disparaître ce
matin thierry breton le pdg de thomson
multimédia annonce donc une quasi
renaissance retour des bénéfices en 98
et surtout entrer en bourse de la
société
la priorité aux spécialités maison comme
les écrans de télévision et
l'investissement massif dans les
nouvelles technologies comme les
lecteurs de cd rom ont permis ce
développement pour la direction cette
privatisation permet de passer à la
vitesse supérieure aujourd'hui l'entrée
en bourse pour thomson multimédia grâce
à l'autorisation que ne l'est le
gouvernement c'est pour nous la
possibilité de faire appel au marché
pour lever des fonds et accélérer encore
notre développement en fait si l'état
reste majoritaire dans l'entreprise il
accepte la mise sur le marché de 29
millions d'actions qui devrait rapporter
entre 3 milliards et demi et 4 milliards
de francs à l'entreprise un événement
lorsqu on sait qu il y a trois ans alain
juppé est chouette a bradé comme sun
multimédia aux coréens des buts
aujourd'hui en grande difficulté
thomson multimédia je le répète ça vaut
un franc symbolique après
recapitalisation parce que dans les
tacles les choses ça ne vaut rien ça
vaut des dettes ça vaut 14 milliards de
dettes une erreur de jugement
aujourd'hui flagrante si les dettes ont
été en grande partie épongée par l'état
à hauteur de 11 milliards de francs
l'entreprise est aussi redresser
d'elle-même elle a déjà réussi à rallier
microsoft nec et alcatel à ses projets
après l'ouverture du capital thomson
multimédia devrait valoir entre 15 et 17
milliards de francs
et ce nouvel exemple de désengagement de
l'état dans l'industrie s'ajoute à une
série impressionnante de privatisation
ou de retrait partiel de la présence de
l'état dans de nombreuses entreprises
sous un gouvernement gauche le rythme de
l'émancipation des entreprises publiques
s'est accéléré l'explication jean
bernard schmidt
cela avait tout l'air d'un baptême
vendredi dernier en compagnie de gerhard
schröder lionel jospin fêter la
naissance du groupe aéronautique
européen eads
un événement qui signifie du même coup
la privatisation définitive
d'aérospatiale l'enthousiasmé
d'aujourd'hui est bien éloigné de la
fermeté d'hier la privatisation c'est la
droite qu'on ne s'attende pas à ce que
la gauche mais la politique de la droite
au pouvoir depuis deux ans lionel jospin
s'est bien rattrapé banque assurance
industrie l'état s'est désengagé au
moins partiellement de nombreuses
entreprises de france télécom à air
france en passant par le gan où le
crédit lyonnais une position difficile à
tenir pour la gauche qui se défendent en
affirmant qu'il ne s'agit pas réellement
de privatisation puisque l'état garde
souvent une participation en fait c'est
le pragmatisme qui l'a emporté
il me semble qu'ils aient un certain
nombre de forces qui explique
l'accélération des privatisations en
france depuis 97 le renforcement de la
concurrence est ce qu'on appelle la
globalisation
l'arrivée de l'euro également qui est un
facteur important
il a nécessité pour un certain nombre
d'entreprises françaises de passer des
alliances en particulier des alliances
européennes en trois époques les
privatisations on rapportait beaucoup à
l'état 100 puis 140 milliards mais le
record est atteint depuis 97 avec 150
milliards de francs et ce n'est
certainement pas fini les participations
publiques dans de grandes sociétés comme
air france france télécom ou renault
sont évaluées à 400 milliards une somme
qui pourrait susciter bien des
tentations
demain à l'assemblée nationale les
députés devraient adopter en première
lecture le projet de seconde loi sur les
35 heures les entreprises privées de
plus de 20 salariés devront passer aux
35 heures à partir du 1er janvier
prochain et les plus petites à partir du
1er janvier 2002 le temps de travail
effectif a été redéfini le lien entre
les aides de l'état et les plans sociaux
à la demande des communistes a été
précisé en attendant le vote par la
majorité plurielle de cette seconde loi
nous avons voulu ce soit révoqué l'une
des pistes permettant l'application des
35 heures à savoir le compte épargne
temps il j de respecter l'engagement de
limitation du temps de travail en créant
une sorte de capital temps utilisable
par le salarié de manière souple depuis
la loi de 1994 ce conte est peinte en
est déjà en vigueur dans plusieurs
entreprises ainsi à limoges dans une
banque régionale où se sont rendus
laurent bailly et maryse richard ne dit
pas à jean-claude jardin qu'il est à la
retraite il trouve que ça fait vieux et
en plus ce n'est pas tout à fait prêt
certes il vient de quitter son
entreprise et vaque à ses occupations
mais il n'a que cinquante huit ans et
continue de toucher sa paye en tant que
salarié son secret depuis trois ans il
versait une partie de ses congés sur un
compte épargne temps et surtout
convertissez son 13e mois et ses
nombreuses primes en journée
supplémentaire pour aller plus vite et
partir plus tôt il y en a qui sont
cigale donne qui sont fourmis je suis
plutôt fourmi donc ça ne pas coûter
beaucoup de faire un effort pour habré
en profiter et partir avant l'âge jean
claude a gagné deux ans sur sa vie
active chez son ancien employeur le
comté paris tend à intéresser 75
salariés sur 450 certains très récemment
ils ont donc peu de jours de vente
trois jours nippon s'est pas beaucoup là
il ya d'abord les stakhanovistes le
compte épargne-temps leur permet de ne
plus renoncer un certain jour de congé
et au cou de l'etei un délai franc de
match pourra les garder et puis c'est
quelque chose qu'on épargne ça nous
donne bonne conscience d'épargné et puis
il ya les vrais faune des prévoyants qui
se projette à cinq ou dix ans peut-être
qu'un jour je redeviens un congé
sabbatique j'en profiterais mais très
honnêtement l'objectif c'est un départ à
la retraite peut-être plus tôt que prévu
ce sont surtout les cadres ce qui
procède à ce genre de calcul
d'employés en revanche peuvent se
permettre de renoncer aux heures
supplémentaires ou aux primes afin
d'alimenter un compte épargne temps
disons qu'il faudrait que ça soit
inversement proportionnelle à la feuille
de paye ou classique quoi pour que ce
sera vraiment bien perçue par les
employés mais bon faut pas rêver
du côté de l'emploi c'est m on ne
remplace vraiment que les départs en pré
retraite c'est le seul cas si quelqu'un
prend un congé sabbatique
par exemple trois mois on peut pas
imaginer que ça va être créateur
d'emplois je dis peut-être à la limite
un cdd pendant quelques temps en 5 ans
une centaine d'entreprises seulement ont
installé un conseil par le temps des
bulles timide pour un dispositif qui se
développera peut-être avec le passage
aux 35 heures
la france demeure le premier partenaire
économique de l'algérie c'est donc une
très forte représentation des
entreprises françaises qui participent
actuellement à la foire internationale
d'alger c'était pourtant pas évident
compte tenu des problèmes de sécurité
mais les changements déjà visibles en
algérie depuis l'élection du président
bouteflika sans encourager les sociétés
françaises qui craignent aussi la
concurrence étrangère on est encore loin
de conditions de travail sereine une
équipe de france 2 avec alban nicosie et
diane richards a pu visiter les locaux
d'une société pharmaceutique française
qui elle n'a jamais quitté le territoire
algérien
alger hier matin
l'ambiance sur la ville est à l'image du
temps on croit percevoir une tendance à
l'éclaircie
alger où se déroule la foire
internationale il y à issy de nouveautés
très révélatrice la foule après sept ans
de marasme les algériens consomment ta
nouveau signe d'un certain optimisme et
surtout la foire n'a pas d'
internationale que le nom 24 pays dont
la france représentée par une centaine
d'entreprises dans un pavillon protégés
par l'armée les français sont de retour
certains d'entre eux n'étaient jamais
partis
alger une zone industrielle à l'est de
la ville dans ses entrepôts sont
stockées et conditionner des médicaments
halde a fait une filiale du groupe
pierre fabre parmi ses dirigeants un
français n'a jamais cessé d'être présent
même au temps les plus difficiles
fait complètement isolé il ya eu une
époque où personne ne venant si les amis
ne venait pas les soutenir viendrait
jamais grâce aux algériens cas ici parce
que j'étais cajoler j'étais reçu j'étais
protégé l'an qui avait aucune raison et
j'ai peur dans cette entreprise caméras
éteintes certains nous diront les
difficultés et les angoisses les
familles placé en france pour leur
sécurité sylvestre poulain dit que les
choses ont désormais évolué au point
qu'un projet industriel existe cette
usine de production de médicaments
français en kabylie moi il est arrivés
des dizaines de fois puisque je viens
régulièrement l'algérie d'être le seul
français dans la vidéo aujourd'hui c'est
là où on semble que l'algérie démarre il
faut réserver ses places fortes aralar
ans pour pouvoir les français premier
fournisseur de l'algérie sont incités à
investir dans les futures entreprises
privatisées voilà le sens de la
convention signée hier soir le président
bouteflika
est en train de mettre très clairement
en place les conditions d'un
développement de l'économie algérienne
et de sa meilleure insertion dans
l'économie mondiale et en même temps
dans le partenariat
attaque une lente et analyste chez bahl
pour massif qu'elle soit la présence des
pme français d'ici à la foire d'alger ne
peut faire oublier qu'en matière
économique ce sont les grosses
entreprises du compte et force est de
reconnaître que depuis in an la france
est pratiquement absent en israël
plusieurs milliers de colons juifs sont
venus manifester hier soir à jérusalem
devant la résidence du premier ministre
ehud barak c'est que l'on protestent
contre le démantèlement voulue par
monsieur barack de colonies de
peuplement sauvage en cisjordanie
correspondant charles enderlin
c'était la première manifestation de
colons contre ehud barak depuis son
arrivée au pouvoir ces jeunes scored
ehud à la maison
et ses affiches veulent dire jérusalem
sera la prochaine cible les
organisateurs appellent leurs mouvements
la génération de la continuité il est
censé représenter la seconde génération
née dans les implantations ils
entendaient protester ainsi contre
l'accord conclu entre le gouvernement
israélien et le conseil des
implantations au terme duquel douze
colonies construites illégalement en
cisjordanie seront évacués mais genre
ici une bonne pâte violence
ni kaka veut perdre la raison mais je ne
pense pas que l'ambiance qu'on voit ici
les gens chantent et dansent entre eux
et leur message ehud barak en tout cas
fait patte de velours envers le
mouvement des implantations il a
autorisé 30 des 42 colonies construites
à la hâte avant les élections en mai
dernier comme le montrent ces images il
s'agit en général de maisons
préfabriquées installé à quelques
centaines de mètres d'implantations
existantes
pour les palestiniens c'est une
véritable relance inacceptable de la
colonisation
c'est une sphère palestinienne il faut
enlever ses colonies c'est une tromperie
ce n'est pas ainsi que monsieur barack
établira la confiance et que pourront
commencer les négociations sur le statut
définitif
des mouvements pacifistes israéliens eux
non plus ne comprennent pas la politique
menée par ehud barak envers les
implantations autorisant certaines
interdisant d'autres il suscite la
colère des palestiniens et des colons et
même de sa gauche
en tchétchénie les troupes russes sont
entrées dans les faubourgs de grozny la
capitale elle n'aurait pas en avant très
moindre résistance clé ce touriste et
tchétchènes refuse de négocier avec ceux
qu'ils appellent les terroristes de
moscou commentaires gerais bec
l'une des rares images de grosses ni
alors que l'armée russe est aux portes
de la ville nos confrères de la
télévision allemande nous font découvrir
une ville inquiète en partie détruite
par les bombardements et déjà vidé d'une
partie de ses habitants je ne sais pas
dit cette femme si les russes vont nous
garder vivant
je suis né ici répond cet homme et je
mourrai ici mais j'espère pas tout de
suite
et puis ces autres images qui ont bien
voulu nous montrer les autorités russes
des chars qui pacifie un pays sans
vraiment rencontrer de résistance
la guerre racontée aux enfants devient
mois et demie que dure le conflit les
journalistes sont confrontés à cette
politique de désinformation
officiellement selon le kremlin le bilan
serait de 178 morts côté russe et 2500
côté tchétchène des chiffres qui
laissent rêveur lorsque l'on connaît la
protée des combats ce soir l'armée russe
assiègent grozny mais à moscou le
ministre des nationalités a déclaré que
l'assaut ne serait pas donner
à l'indonésie à jakarta les
parlementaires se sont mis d'accord à
l'unanimité pour accepter l'accession du
timor oriental à l'indépendance et
députés indonésiens accepte de tenir
compte du vote acquis lors du référendum
du 31 août dernier où les habitants du
timor oriental s'étaient prononcés à une
très forte majorité en faveur de
l'indépendance en catalogne les
élections régionales hier reconduit les
nationalistes de jordi pujol qui sont au
pouvoir un pouvoir qu'ils éteignent
qu'ils détiennent depuis
1981 et jordi pujol a eu chaud mais
socialistes ont très fortement progressé
gagnant 12 sièges ils n'ont que quatre
sièges de retard sur les nationalistes
en corse la démolition des paillotes et
commencer d'ici au 30 octobre elles
devront avoir disparu du littoral
plusieurs propriétaires ont préféré
prendre les devants en faisant preuve de
bonne volonté à défaut de bonne fortune
reportage olivier théron hervé pozzo
jean marc a jolly s'y était engagé il
détruirait sa paillote illégal pour la
fin octobre alors ce matin après avoir
récupéré ce qui pouvait l'être et brûlé
le reste il a tenu promesse la mort dans
l'âme ce même temps tu suives a duré
neuf ans je suis là depuis 1981 paris ça
fait évidemment
le restaurant était pas comme ça au
départ il a grandi avec le temps et avec
mes besoins
ils sont neuf exploitants de plage à
être dans ce cas installée il ya 20 ans
et puis dit il de la loi littoral et de
la réglementation sur le domaine public
maritime qui interdit toute construction
en bord de mer sur la même plage de
coti-chiavari emile carta est en train
de démonter son restaurant il a repris
sa cuisine l'année dernière pour être
aux normes mais lui aussi a épuisé tous
les recours judiciaires il devra
détruire c'est le préalable imposée par
le nouveau préfet jean pierre lacroix
j'espère j'espère pouvoir obtenir
quelque chose va pas de monsieur lacroix
là on est vraiment dans l'inconnu nous a
demandé de démolir on me démolir on
verra ensuite on met ensuite ils
espèrent tous convaincre les pouvoirs
publics de l'importance des paillotes
pour préserver l'emploi et protéger
l'environnement ils ont l'hiver pour
discuter pour présenter leur projet il
ya encore 200 paillote illégale sur
l'île leur exploitons aussi attendent de
voir les solutions mises en oeuvre pour
composer avec la loi
alliant quelques 500 étudiants de
l'université lyon 2 se sont mis en grève
ce matin pour protester contre les
sureffectifs et le manque de moyens
cette université fait exception puisque
les inscriptions à la rentrée ont
augmenté de 12% reportage à lyon helen
hughes et bernard on flaire amphi bloqué
salle de cours vidés de leur mobilier
les étudiants de l'université de lyon ii
ont voté la grève ce matin ils dénoncent
le manque de moyens ils nous ont inscrit
mais le problème c'est que ils ont pas
suivi les falaises ou n'ont pas suivi ce
qui fait que l'on n'était je sais pas
vous mais on était trop en fille mais
mon premier cours que j'ai passé lundi
dernier j'étais assise dans les marches
comment suivre un cours à 6 dans les
marchés impossible en italien de se
retrouver 66 pour un td pour une salle
de 45 donc déjà une salle de 45 c'est
énorme et 66 il y en avait qui étaient
conclus mur presque dehors
le problème trouvait depuis l'été en
juillet près de 300 étudiants n'avaient
pu s'inscrire en première année dans la
filière de leur choix il ya trois
semaines après avoir occupé la
présidence de l'université la moitié
d'entre eux ont obtenu une place où il
le souhaitait conséquence logique les
capacités d'accueil sont dépassées en
psychologie et en arts du spectacle les
étudiants sont en surnombre
effectivement le premier droit de
l'étudiant et de rentrer à l'université
dans la figure de son choix mais son 2e
droite et envoyé deux fois avoir des
conditions d'études acceptable à lyon 2
pour cette rentrée les effectifs en
première année ont augmenté de 10%
l'engouement pour les filières psycho et
arts du spectacle rend la situation
difficile où effectivement le s'inscrire
tout le monde
contre vents et marées contre toute
raison pédagogique
mais il faut des amphis suffisamment
grand ce que nous n'avons pas toujours
il faut des moyens suffisants ou on
considère qu'il y à des seuils timo ont
relativement petit mot au delà desquels
nous ne souhaitons pas nous engager
demain les étudiants de lyon ii iront
manifester aux côtés des lycéens leurs
revendications sont en tout point
semblable
des pluies des rafales de vent des
tempêtes les intempéries ont sévi
notamment dans le sud-ouest en languedoc
roussillon d'un département de l'hérault
et de l'aveyron avec parfois de petites
tornades et plusieurs personnes et ont
été évacués par hélicoptère s'était près
de saint-affrique commentaires stéphanie
savariaud
la montée des eaux a surpris tout le
monde à vabres-l'abbaye dans l'aveyron
jusqu au secours qui ont dû évacuer sans
que personne par hélicoptère
les fortes pluies qui ont touché le
département ce matin ont provoqué des
éboulements et inondé quelques cases les
pompiers sont intervenus plus de 60 fois
autres départements touchés l'hérault
une mini tornade s'est abattue sur la
commune de lavérune des vents
tourbillonnants ont dépassé les 100
kilomètres heure arrachant les toits de
dizaines de maisons
quand j'essaie de m'en faire là la
maison j'arrive à fermer la porte et
toute la maison est partie leurs
factures fable
j'ai rien compris
aux alentours de montpellier il est
tombé plus de 200 mm d'eau en quelques
heures météo france prévoit une nuit
calme pour les deux départements mais
craint une reprise des intempéries dans
la soirée de mercredi
jusqu'au 24 octobre c'est la semaine de
la science histoire de susciter des
vocations scientifiques et d'accroître
l'intérêt du public pour tous les
domaines de recherche 2000 200
manifestations sont prévues alors dans
le domaine de l'infiniment petit notre
curiosité était attiré par la
réalisation d'un laboratoire du
commissariat à l'énergie atomique qui
vient de mettre au point le plus petit
transistor du monde il s'agit d'une puce
une toute petite puce vraiment tout
petit et qui a besoin de rester très
propre comme l'indiquent jean-claude
allanic et claude sicard
l'ennemi des puces c'est la poussière
l'hygiène est ici encore plus
draconiennes que dans une salle
d'opération alors avant de découvrir le
plus petit transistor du monde ont fui
dans ce laboratoire de grenoble il faut
commencer par se débarrasser de toutes
traces de particules polluantes
c'est là dans cette salle où même la
lumière est étudiée que les chercheurs
du cea ont réussi l'exploit fabriquer un
transistor de 20 nanomètres 20
millionième de millimètre al ahram être
sélective allant d'un cheveu dans un
terrain de football d'ailleurs pour
l'utiliser un microscope électronique à
balayage qui grossit jusqu'à 100000 fois
pour voir un transistor vous voyez sur
cette image gros si cette fois-ci 500
mille fois voici le coeur du nouveau
transistor il est capable de traiter des
dizaines de milliards d'informations à
la seconde tout en étant dix fois plus
petit que tout ce qui existe déjà
les plaques de silicium dans des
équipements entièrement automatisé dans
lesquels des robots ont manipulé les
plaquettes il n'y a pas d'intervention
humaine
reste à passer de l'exploit en
laboratoire à la phase industrielle
cela devrait prendre encore une
quinzaine d'années mais les applications
seront alors très concrètes j'avais donc
là une carte de téléphone portable sur
lequel il ya plusieurs circuits intégrés
un chacun siècle intégré il ya des
centaines de millions de transistors si
nous arrivons à faire les transistors
plus petits nous pourrons regrouper des
sacs intérêts dans toutes ses fonctions
sur un stage cirque intègre une
miniaturisation qui permettrait par
exemple de ce qu'est dans une goutte
d'eau l'équivalent d'un milliard de
pages autrement dit tous les livres de
la bibliothèque nationale
en sport automobile ferrari occupe une
place prestigieuse et c'est donc tout un
drame que la disqualification programmée
des deux ferrari hier en malaisie alors
qu'elle venait de l'emporter sur le
circuit de ses parts mais ce triomphe
était suspect aux yeux des commissaires
qui ont découvert sur les formule 1 un
rouge
plusieurs millimètres de trop dé mm qui
auraient faussé la course récit
christelle bertrand en formule 1 pour
gagner il ne suffit pas de franchir la
ligne le premier il faut aussi que la
voiture soit aux normes chaque détail
compte même la dimension des ailerons
ceux de ferrari ont un centimètre de
trop et 1 cm ça peut tout changer
qui s'est fait volontairement sciemment
par les ingénieurs qui passent des
heures et des heures en soufflerie pour
améliorer le rendement du
refroidissement des moteurs l'efficacité
la finesse aérodynamique du
fonctionnement des dé fond plat et bien
se sont dits peu puni mètres de chaque
côté qui peuvent avoir une influence
très très grande et importante pour
l'instant chez ferrari on se défend
comme on peut les voitures sont équipées
des mêmes déflecteur depuis le grand
prix du nürburgring lors des
vérifications
les commissaires n'ont rien remarqué la
scuderia aurait donc été dénoncé par une
écurie concurrente ferrari reconnaît son
erreur mais se défend d'avoir voulu
tricher
walkie millimétré quelques millimètres
comme je les ai déjà dit des taux ne
peuvent pas avoir d'incidence sur le
comportement de la voiture sous les
présélectionnés et la main qui donne en
italie la presse- tire à boulet rouge
sur la fédération internationale échappe
tifosi à son avis sur l'exclusion des
ferrari je pense tout simplement que
certains ne veulent pas que ferrari
remporte le titre mondial
je constate quand les autres gagnent n'y
a jamais de protéger alors que quand on
gagne nous il y a toujours des problèmes
ferrari a fait appel de la décision des
commissaires du grand prix verdict
vendredi prochain à paris pour un
centimètre la scuderia passera peut-être
à côté du titre mondial
en voile dès le début de la transat le
havre carthagène le trimaran brocéliande
d'alain gautier et michel desjoyeaux a
chaviré au large du cotentin les deux
navigateurs ont dû chevauchée leur
embarcation toute la nuit avant d'être
remorqué vers les côtes françaises il
devrait atteindre 10 à l'ept c'est un
pote enfin que ce soir avant minuit
et puis dans les mers australes pour la
coupe de l'america les éliminatoires ont
permis aux défis français de remporter
une victoire et de subir une défaite
c'est un début convenable pour
l'équipage tricolore commentaires
christophe duchiron
au terme de leurs deux premières régates
disputées ce lundi à auckland les
français du défi sixième sens ont
déclaré qu'il n'était ni content
mécontent ce qui est finalement logique
lorsque l'on a connu une victoire et une
défaite avec leurs bateaux spi blanc et
à la coque orange vif ils ont subi une
défaite que l'on qualifiera de très
honorables face au légendaire américain
dennis conner double vainqueur de la
coupe de l'america les français ne vont
s'incliner que de neuf petites secondes
au prix d'une très belle mais tardive
remontée
pour la deuxième régate l'adversaire
était modeste liang australia 2000 le
moins fortunés des participants un vieux
bateau est un skipper de 19 ans
forcément inexpérimentés il n'empêche
que les australiens ont pris un meilleur
départ et à la première bouée il possède
30 secondes avant sur les français des
français qui vont finir par prendre
l'aventage et l'emporter avec plus de
cinq minutes d'avancé marquant ainsi
leurs premiers points dans la
compétition
il reste à ce jour trois mois deux
régates pour atteindre les demi finales
la route est encore longue
du rugby demain les français fabien
pelous et christian califano devront
comparaître devant la commission
discipline des coûts du monde la suite
d'incidents survenus vers de france 8 10
a dit à toulouse alors autant pour
pelous la faute semble avéré regardez
ils piétinent le visage d'un adversaire
à terre
autant pour christian califano c'est
nettement moins clair le choc semble
avoir lieu entre une tatline épaules
malgré le geste du fidjien ils risquent
tous les deux pelous et califano d'être
suspendue pour les quarts de finale avec
l'équipe de france
du cinéma avait tout d'abord l'annoncé
de l'acquisition phare le court français
ugc des salles du groupe virgin en
grande bretagne et en irlande ugc
devient le premier réseau européen et
puis mercredi sur les écrans le dernier
film du japonais takeshi kitano il est
dans son pays à mi chemin de l'animateur
télé de la star de cinéma son film est
une ballade mi comique mi tendre d'un
enfant de 7 ans à travers le japon en
compagnie d'un quinquagénaire un peu
déglingué
jouée par takeshi kitano lui-même
représentation de pascal deschamps
les apparitions des apparitions de
kitano sont plutôt rares en europe tant
ses occupations sont nombreuses au japon
toujours prêt à surprendre son monde cet
ancien danseur et clones de cabaret a
choisi cette fois d'explorer tout un
monde de fantaisie qui tranche avec
l'univers des malfrats après bangalore
c'est un peu comme si je servais un
repas
et pour une fois j'ai voulu varier les
nets
d'habitude je fais du riz les films de
gangsters et là je sors de poisson j'ai
voulu m'amuser et amuser les spectateurs
massés
dans l'été de kikujiro il revisite un
thème qu'on croyait pourtant refusé
l'amitié d'un adulte bourru et d'un
petit orphelin mais quitte à ne le
renouvelle en mêlant sans cesse la
poésie et l'humour il faudrait avec les
spectateurs un album dimanches colorer
les pas mièvre à l'école de la vie
kitano et ses héros emprunte les chemins
de traverse
non
kita n'en fait plus que nous amuser il
fait de nous des enfants libres et
farceur m kitano merci à lee gâteau pour
ce pur moment de bonheur
et
c'est mercredi sur les écrans nous
arrivons à la fin de cette édition je
rappelle trois informations que nous
avons développées tout d'abord
l'ouverture à guingamp du procès de
l'abbé cottard ce prêtre intégriste jugé
après la mort en 98 de cinq personnes
dont quatre scouts où il y avait la
responsabilité
puis l'ouverture à evry d'un autre
procès celui de l' affaire dite des
emplois fictifs au conseil général de
l'essonne xavière tiberi les polymères
de paris figure parmi les prévenus et
puis nissan sous contrôle de renault
procède à la fermeture de cinq usines et
prévoit la suppression de 21 mille
emplois au japon
la météo dans quelques instants avec
nathalie rihouet et puis line renaud
dans la petite fille ou costumes arras
sylvain attal d'argent public à 22h40 et
laurence ostolaza 01 55 pour le dernier
journal de la rédaction j'ai retrouvé
ensuite alain duhamel tour l'entretien
avec claire bretécher demain à 13h
carole gaessler et rachid arhab à demain
20h bonsoir merci
pas